oh
that doesn't sound very good
whoa
that doesn't sound very good i think it
hit my trap i got a little x on my mind
he did yeah he's standing in it get him
kill him kill him he ran over him oh oh
what
wait how do i stay in that trap for very
little zip lining
oh zipline i see i see i see bob there's
ammo for you in there
uh hey mark there's a bear
it's a bomb
what the hell is a bear
okay was there vicious wildlife before
in this game yeah there was like wolves
and stuff i think
no oh
i butchered it
oh cool is that good yep just bones now
don't worry boys i'm on my way and i'm
loaded to the teeth with ammunation
good i wanna oh there's no way to
zipline what
no
it's just it's just an aesthetic thing
oh there's gotta be a way to zip line
that
oh there is a way to zipline that how
just jump and hold space guys i think
he's on me just jump and hold spoons
okay i'm dying to a wolf
is that a raccoon
i thought raccoon took this bullet like
nothing
oh my god i'm coming to help you
hey bart
oh hey what's up dude i don't see a
raccoon jump i jump and hold space not
like that
can you go back up [ __ ] that you can go
back up
[Laughter]
well this is officially the best part of
this game
all right i'm here to help with the
raccoon wolf bear where is the good job
man uh it's all good we're good it looks
like there's more buildings up the hill
here i don't like bob are you still here
no we're out of there
there's a bandana
near a banana and the bandanna has a
face
what are you talking about what is this
is it a pumpkin win oh it's 93 guys just
so you don't no it's i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is i say we go up to
whatever this building is up here and
make this our standoff for the night
maybe it looks like leather face and
pizza the hut had a baby this is
wonderful that you found this wade but
we also have a bigfoot to worry about
i've handled him several times now all
right
that seems pretty cool it seems pretty
cool are these explody barrels no
they're empty
oh oh what was that oh
bear
where
bear bear
coming around
where is around i don't know it's on the
other side of that big guest tree hey
guys and i'm going to set some traps
just on this main road here so watch out
wade
bears things to me
i
don't know why i'd be called out for
something like that bear seems to be a
little baby
oh hey my favorite show's on um
i'm gonna close this door
all right wait maybe we yeah maybe we um
yeah bobby
out the window for those traps i guess
you want to watch the show it's a good
show whoa there's a safe
a safe with a code
interesting okay oh that's a reason i
turn on a lantern over by your traps
thanks so one of the notes
must have a code
now what if the code was written on some
of these blinds but you had to close the
blinds to see that'd be fun
campfire guitar
who's to use the night vision camera all
of us i don't have one mark search the
uh search those two things there's a
trap here too there's nine million more
oh yeah
hey guys you feel that rumble oh wow
that's not where our trips are
oh my god oh the door the door
wait you're leading him very much away
from the traps to the traps i'm coming
to the traps
you just hit a trap it's fine
[Music]
man he ran right over that trap i
triggered already my [ __ ]
he's in the trap he said they're going
to get him
i'm out of ammo
the flare did not seemingly work
hey the moon's pretty cool hey guys uh
mark you want to set some more traps or
something yeah yeah you got it trap's
coming down here we go blam trap all
right
oh he's really grabbing me don't worry
wade please dear god look
come here you come here big guy oh
we did it um
good thing he doesn't heal over time and
we did a very small amount oh [ __ ]
i'll put a good drop down oh i have meat
do we not do we want to bait the traps
with meat you could you could i can't i
don't have meat why don't i have meat i
cannot drop these things
i don't know what are you trying to drop
a fuel canister or the gas thing to see
if we could shoot those on him no it's
probably for something like generator or
something yeah
who's playing
i'm bringing him back don't worry boys
hmm man i feel like i should probably be
anywhere else right now oh
oh i think he's coming don't worry guys
i have a car battery what's that dude
i don't know but i can put it on the
ground
wait the weird pizza mask is on this
table too what are you talking about a
pizza mask don't look at this table back
here do i want to under the banana
there's some kind of weird [ __ ] face
thing
i hate it i think you mean
a slice of pizza
look at it though it's got two olives
and like a sausage on it that are kind
of kind of a face shape kind of that is
a horrible
that's pizza the hot motherface baby and
i won't hear anything else i it's just
it's just pizza is this are we supposed
to be like fortifying the rv so that he
attacks so we've got cameras and we do
and we then we
something
okay where's the auto turret defense
system
yeah how do we buy um how do we buy wall
don't know man he must be getting tokens
or points or something can we start
farming can we start a farm to get some
healing i really wanna i see him uh
on the other side of the river oh
i have a solution for that
right he didn't even know it didn't even
feel it wow i'm apparently not hitting
him wait get him did he die where'd he
go
he's swimming
nope he's dead oh he's right there he's
running away
that's right that's right you better run
apparently he's in no mood
yeah he's in no mood oh he's all
depressed
what's the matter bullets got your top
tongue
got him
you still see him wade
no he ran up the hill
oh big baby are you guys chased after
him i'm gonna go try to find some more
ammo seems like a good plan well yeah we
know where he is he's down that way it's
as good as time as any for me to go
through
right here
this seems like a great spot what is
this there's a
camera symbol and some scratches on this
log take a picture of it i don't have a
camera
all right i have the camera mark come to
us i was supposed to take a picture of
him ah you really uh you really screwed
it up mark i did i'm sorry this is a big
ass hey guys i found a i found a poop
hole oh it's a very shallow poop hole
that's barely a hole at all that's more
of a poop on the ground situation is it
want a photo of it we need a photo of
the poop if it's got a camera symbol
then we definitely need a photo of that
oh i found the code the code oh god
the code eight four zero six remember
that
nope eight four zero six eight four zero
there's a shotgun in here
grab it oh mark you can have a shotgun
too i'm gonna go over and check the safe
and see what this code opens and then
i'll come to you i'll circle back i
found a little bit of ammo but not much
eight four zero six
oh whoa
dynamite
my gosh my dudes
oh uh
one of you i found another totem for
reviving if one of us dies ah [ __ ] well
mark's coming to you right i'm coming to
you i'm almost there wait hold on
holding
hold on
river's very slow
there was a bridge river's very slow i
found the good dynamite
i got a good dynamite guys
off the zipline
another one
oh yeah there's a different one oh yeah
there's okay
this is a big boy zipline oh my
got it big boy zipline we're on our way
to zip with you oh you're way down there
yeah i'm running i'm checking i'm
scoping it out
turns out you can't heal without healing
item
you need healing i think i got an extra
one guys i found call trees grove
village
uh
that's uh i was wrong i do not i
baltimore all right
false hope rebellions are built on false
hope oh i found another safe what was
the code is it possible that works here
too eight four zero six you could try
well that's not the code for this safe
all right we're almost there bob
no worries i'm just getting all the loot
okay
to share right
um
oh yeah yeah
family and now you're dead give me your
meat okay
wow
what
i was talking to the deer i killed
hey i found some pistol ammo and some
shotgun ammo to share right
what was that what is that what is that
what is that
what is that what is that
i came from over where you were bob i
know it came from really close to me
yeah investigating the bonging
investigation unsuccessful
this thing is barricaded hey
boys
yes your boy
back together again
i'm gonna give mark a shotgun and some
ammo for it
okay
wait no i just found an r 700 here
this grandfather clock just dangling on
an r700
is that an assault rifle that's the
that's the sniper rifle that i'm using
do you want a shotgun or that no no no
give all the ammo to wade was that him
okay do you think that was him yeah i
think it was oh i'm gonna put a trap out
because i have done how much ammo do you
have for your r 700 mark uh like 20 i
think uh come here oh hell yeah come
here kidding oh wait one eight five nine
here's the code where's that gun safe uh
it's somewhere in here i am giving you
please watch out for the trap in the
middle of the road here great success
herpes oh hopeless listen herpes oh it
had a bunch of ammo in it nice oh and
the avm
the av that sounds like an upgraded
sniper rifle it is an upgraded sniper
rifle
what ammo's that one take the same 762.
all right
if he comes for us i have dynamite i'm
going to put it through this gap here
oh yeah yeah yeah right here you may
turn the megaphone on and try to lure
him yeah sure
[Music]
i just went around the log
oh i didn't realize that was an option
all right i do not know how to throw
this dynamite
so i might whiff him big time
if you if you light it in your hand
uh yell run and we will leave you to
suffer all i know is g for go boom all
right maybe i was pretty mature maybe
i'll turn the mic phone back on well it
did go right he's blonging you hear him
no
he's just
oh he's bonking
oh
that sounds like a bonker
i'm gonna get closer to the thing i
think this will one shot him i'm almost
positive
i am i believe in you fully confident
somebody looking for some dinner
there he is he's here oh he's here he's
here he's here i'm coming okay go go go
go go go go go watch out for the driver
it did nothing
it really didn't do very much
well
i'm gonna watch what's your next
strategy mark oh
trap down run right under his feet he'll
never know oh he's got him he's running
with the trap
he's reached a new level
he's ascended
oh i'm gonna die good night no you're
not
oh oh oh now you might not happy about
you okay yeah oh wow i think i died
thank you
um hey what if i um did this
can you can you bring him back or
something no look at your look at the
totem in your inventory it will guide
you all right mark you do that i'll
fight him off single handedly the totem
in my inventory
oh okay something when you hover over it
though does it say like take the totem
somewhere it says holy to take does it
mean your butt i took your body oh hey
buddy
oh boy okay this team's good
i don't know what to do with him but i
have him
hey what's up dead wade
you're so strong mark thank you i bear
the weight of my burdens through my
sorrow wait do you know where we're
supposed to go no i i can't look at my
inventory right now but i swear whenever
i hit i and i looked at the totem it
said you could use it to bring someone
back i just don't remember how yeah oh
okay you just put them on the ground
the totem's on the ground go towards the
totem you can use the soda reviver fred
with stonehenge oh [ __ ] oh he discovers
tonehenge yet right that's right we
gotta find stonehenge
no you're right don't you guys know
where stonehill hinges and redwood oh
don't worry buddy i'm gonna help you
he might be watching
i just freshly killed two deer and put
four meats in my archery range there you
go oh wow that sounds funny might be a
gun there
oh no i don't think there's no there's
bows though there's bows
can't use that that's not a weapon oh
that's stupid i don't know why that
dynamite did nothing this is unfair he
did a good amount of damage he's at like
half ish oh he's not eating any of that
he's feeding oh boy is that a new totem
that's a new totem
oh and grab another
okay you got that i this is my maximum
speed by the way so uh
scout ahead look for stone engine i'll
just oh sure yeah oh nothing bad will
happen all right wait listen
yeah i don't know how to tell you this
but
i'm always gonna be there for you
and that sounded like it was going to be
bad news when you know when i say i
don't know how to tell you this
it did yeah but i'm acting bad i meant
that in like a little bit i felt i meant
like it was like in an emotionally
supportive and difficult to say way but
look we need to have a talk wade oh
well now
i've been a mistake i care very deeply
about you and i i i look forward to
seeing you alive and well again
the stream fell on me
oh god
that's not good
what do i do what do i do what do i do
about that are you dead i can heal i can
heal oh oh okay why did you all right
oh i got him i got oh my god oh my god
don't worry about it okay all right i'll
scout ahead listen wayne yeah i don't
know how to tell you this yeah please
but mark had to go
[Music]
it's sad that mark died to that tree
incident
we're gonna be fine buddy
i feel like i was just in his loving
arms what was your ball hey you dude
you're slippery slippery boy
oh
yeah all this blood and
stuff hard to hold onto you know so much
to you guys you never leave me but i'll
always come back for you when i throw
your lifeless corpse on the clown
you're good
is that a good series of sounds or a bad
series of sounds who's fine he's fine
he's fine man
he found a natural man-made trap and
stepped right in i did
hazard was his possessive
um
what is happening was i supposed to see
that somehow
i don't know
it was like a quick time event but i
didn't know what was happening so i
didn't know i needed to press something
so
i found all right stone camera
opportunity on your foot
down hinge
bob's at a camera opportunity if you see
where he's right now okay
there's no stone engine at the top of
this mountain which is what i thought
okay well i'm gonna go this way then ah
you're a bear
oh is there fall damage
yes
yes there is this is a zip line i see a
zip line i don't know where it goes
i see a zipline i'm taking it i think
it's coming to where i where i'm going
i'm just coming oh i'm on it
oh you got that i don't know
we
this is a fantastic bigfoot escape this
is definitely
dope as hell you find it some stonehenge
no no stone edge here
where the hell would you be
gotta be like a map or something i don't
know
what's the meaning of stones another
700.
have you guys seen that oh is that a gun
locker
unlocked oh it is a lock gun locker it's
got a green i feel like no one's hanging
out with me i feel like i'm doing the
important job here wait's hanging out
with you i'm moving back and forth it's
just right now you're walking in a
straight line and mark's finding
interesting guns i'm walking in a
straight line towards some tables with
some rats on the ground in front of me
it's a raccoon
is this stonehenge i don't think this is
stonehenge i gotta be honest no
this would be a very disappointing
there's a lot back there you can go
investigate
where oh hey dad wait you want to see a
friend do you want to meet a friend
yeah yeah you want to leave me there for
a minute and go exploring
that sounds good we need a photo op mark
you're missing all the photos
there's nothing i won't survive he's so
close please just go home
just don't forget about me okay zero
wait two seven seven zero hang on i
might have the
there's another gun safe 2770. oh if
that's the case you should meet me up
with him so he can take all that ammo i
got where can stone it must be in the
center
it must be in the center there's like a
gap in the mini map where two roads go
to the center
well [ __ ]
it must be i'll go scout
one second
momentarily actually no i'll meet up
with you i'll bury i'll bear the burden
i'm coming
oh
he found it he got it stonehenge
mark there's ammo on the table in there
hey there's a there's a fox over here
hey buddy oh oh oh oh
i have bear bear wait i'm using your
body as bait
where are you i'm coming to you because
i have 190
bullets for this thing and
oh dear i'm coming to you bob you're
coming to your bottom bears
bob i only have 16 health i have 28
health i'm doing great
watch out for bears and wolves and
everything i should really heal up
out maybe suck the rest of the life out
of my lifeless corpse you have more
health than me right
yeah
take this
take this weapon nope that's a tablet
give me the body
no all right uh wait take
take this
and all of this no seven six two ammo
wait what's that five five six probably
done
make sure i don't have any firefighters
oh my god yeah i'll search you
oh wait i think i gave it to mark
earlier but
here he is that's fine just lay me
around that broken
so many bullets you guys guys all right
you can pick me up off the broken branch
anytime now no if they come anywhere
near us
they're gonna die all right i'll i'll
pick you up i'm just getting the shotgun
because
that's a good idea you can take that all
right must be in the center of the map
mark do you want the better sniper
uh no i figure
he's going to be up close and personal
how many totems do we all have i had i
have like two or something wait there's
a small do you see that there's a
smaller zip line that looks like it goes
towards where we need to go
okay
i don't know if i can carry him with a
zip line but we're going to find out i
can jump with you all right
please zip line together yes use me use
my spine on top of the rope
oh [ __ ] he's literally down there yeah
he's down there
well
all right
about time for me to be hitting the old
dusty trail
um
we're here we're here we're here we're
here we're thinking about the next step
my ass is the heaviest part of me i'm
gonna have a look i'm gonna have a look
i'm gonna have a look have a look have a
look
is he down here he was down here yep
he was the direction of that uh tower
bob he was over that way
i hear something stomping around i'm
looking out from up here can't see much
yeah wait are you watching
yeah looking over i can only spectate
youtube but my body's physically here so
i'm definitely watching all right i'm
gonna take the long way around
with him do you want me to hold down
there or do you want to yeah you go down
there and try to draw them and then uh
zip back up and down and see if that'll
like uh that's a great way to kite him i
think unless actually yeah
i wonder if i can like
oh hey
i'm gonna turn my light off wade i think
i might see him all right we're gonna be
sneaking through this
yeah let's see if i can hold his
attention i guess i see something yellow
glowing i don't know what you're looking
at exactly i think it's a light
oh that's him that's it that's him see
ya
okay
he made
oh that was that was inches three feet
away from him inches
should i come back no no he's fine it's
fine
coming
he hit me while i'm on the zip line
i'm not sure what's happening
i'm dead whoa
no why are you both down i'm down you
know
i don't want your dab why is bob down
i don't no it hit you on the zip line
and then that carried over to the top
i'm bleeding out i'm
down
man
is there any way out of this
he almost didn't go for me i think i
just got a little too close i think he
downed me but i was on the zip line and
then i got to the top was down started
to come back down and then fell off the
zip line ah well we learned some
valuable lessons today we did yes we did
trees and traps
are bad
bigfoot can come in houses
he can and
safe is good
megaphones go wee woo
they do they wee a lot yeah sucks that
we didn't get to shoot the the nice gun
but that's all right yeah i guess i
might as well have been blasting off
there okay well that was good
i'm one oh he's eating he's eating so
cutely though he's all i'm no
well that was a little rough at the end
there good try hey bigfoot survive
wow
on our team or wow i gained 104
experiences
wow
turns out if you die you don't get very
much experience yeah well i actually
like that as an improvement to the game
i think they do yeah
i think that was way better than what we
had played before way better it's still
hard
but we were also kind of [ __ ] around
a lot a little bit a little bit a little
bit
you